depuis le 15 septembre 2021 certains
soignants ne peuvent plus travailler se
faire injecter une dose de vaccin ou se
faire suspendre plusieurs milliers
d'entre eux sont ainsi toujours
suspendus et privés de rémunération
tandis que l'Italie réintègre elle s'est
soignants non vaccinés une réintégration
qui n'est en France toujours pas à
l'ordre du jour je suis la vie des
scientifiques comme depuis le début de
cette crise et cet avis et négatif par
rapport à la rétégration des soignants
certaines voix s'élèvent donc pour
protester contre cette mesure toujours
en vigueur parmi elles l'actrice Annie
Duperey qu'est-ce qu'on attend
15000 soignants prêts à travailler alors
coup de gueule de l'actrice Annie
Duperey faut-il réintégrer les soignants
non vaccinés
alors on va revoir le coup de gueule
d'Annie Duperey et on va en parler dans
un instant avec Florence aide-soignante
suspendu Carnon Maximilien merci
Florence d'être là et on a également
avec nous Dany Foster directeur d'EHPAD
merci Dany
monsieur le ministre monsieur le
ministre il y a 15000 soignants
suspendus pompiers et gendarme qui
n'attendent qu'une chose c'est qu'on les
réintègre comme ils l'ont fait à New
York et comme ils l'ont fait en Italie
qu'est-ce qu'on attend et vous savez ce
que ça veut dire suspendu c'est qu'ils
sont pas licenciés c'est-à-dire qu'ils
n'ont ni chômage ni salaire ça vient du
coeur ça vient du coeur ça vient du
coeur parce que c'est une énorme colère
quand je lis ça mais mon dieu il
faudrait des soyons va-t-on en trouver
va-t-on en trouver enfin
enfin
ils sont là ils sont là
ça a été le gros coup de gueule Daniel
qui a forcément été repris partout et on
voulait absolument avoir une
aide-soignante non vaccinée suspendue ça
fait combien de temps que vous êtes
suspendu Florence alors je remets les
choses alors quand je suis infirmière à
la base de métier avant aide-soignante
aussi et je n'étais pas suspendu avant
là le 7 novembre parce que j'étais en
arrêt maladie pour sauver ma vie et
parce que j'ai des enfants un loyer et
que j'ai pas je savais pas comment faire
autrement et j'ai refusé d'injecter mes
patients parce que pour moi c'était des
personnes vulnérables qui avaient besoin
d'un consentement libre et éclairé et
qu'ils n'ont pas eu et donc voilà j'ai
refusé de les faire injecter ce produit
expérimental encore à l'heure actuelle
et moi aussi par la suite donc voilà
il y a énormément de gens dans
aujourd'hui vous êtes suspendu oui je
suis suspendu ça y est depuis le 7
novembre mais voilà j'étais en arrêt
pour dépression et puis pour pouvoir
survivre parce que les gens ils se
rendent pas compte de la détresse dans
laquelle tous les soignants et pompiers
sont à l'heure actuelle ceux qui sont
suspendus pour avoir refusé juste pour
avoir refusé une injection qui est
encore expérimentale donc ça n'a aucun
sens après c'est la vie de Florence a le
droit de l'exprimer ici comme on dit
tous les avis sont bienvenus et la vie
de Florence est importante on les même
si il y en a qui sont pas d'accord voilà
on va voir la question faut-il
réintégrer les soignants non vaccinés
tout le monde dit oui
pourquoi non parce que personne n'en
veut d'abord il faut savoir qu'en Italie
c'est moi je vais finir ma phrase en
Italie ils ont été réintégrés et ça pose
un énorme problème la communauté
médicale ne veut pas les accepter dans
plein de régions on ne les vaut pas en
France en France visiblement les
personnes vaccinées n'ont pas envie non
plus que ces soignants reviennent et je
comprends parfaitement le drame humain
parfaitement c'est sûr que c'est pas
15000 personnes qui vont sauver
l'hôpital mais vous seriez nécessaire
mais moi je dis non il y a encore des
risques la Haute Autorité de apporter
dit non il y a un risque auprès des
personnes vulnérables donc je dis non
virus ça a été oui donc je ne comprends
pas
pourquoi comme dit Florence ceux qui
sont vaccinés transmettent aussi le
virus donc qu'est-ce qu'elle est le
problème
il y a trop de risques il y a trop de
risques mais quand on est vacciné le
virus aussi oui c'est quoi le problème
oui mais parce qu'on peut transmettre de
manière plus ample ça peut être plus
dangereux mais tous les scientifiques
Cyril tous les scientifiques répondent
non tous les scientifiques
non mais c'est un scandale à partir du
moment où toutes ces mesures étaient
basées sur le fait que soi-disant le
vaccin arrêté la transmission voilà
maintenant qu'on sait que c'est pas vrai
plus rien n'est justifié il faut arrêter
ces soignants sont hors de tout cadre
légal ça fait 400 et quelques jours 420
jours ou quelque chose comme ça qu'ils
n'ont ni salaire ni rsa ni rien pour
subsister pour eux pour leur famille
basée sur une fake news il faut quand
même le dire c'est scandale absolu on
est en pénurie de soignants le le
système pédiatrique s'écroule il y a des
enfants qui sont envoyés à 100 km de
chez eux des bébés parce qu'il y a pas
assez de soignants que ça a arrêté la
transmission que le foot la politesse a
été basé sur cette information qui en
fait c'est avéré être fausse donc il y a
le système hospitalier est en pénurie de
soignant de tous les côtés on est à un
soignant près donc la discussion même
sur les chiffres sur les 15000 c'est pas
15 c'est 5000 et le message qu'on envoie
la dissuasion qu'on envoie aux gens qui
auraient envie de s'engager dans cette
voie le droit au consentement c'est une
des pierres angulaires de toutes les
démocraties voilà si on Bafou le droit
au consentement c'est une catastrophe
démocratique
tout à l'heure vous avez dit j'ai refusé
de faire des injections à des personnes
c'est ça mais je parle du vaccin quand
je parle de l'injection c'est
l'injections
donc c'est pas à vous de décider de si
vous faites des injections ou pas à
partir du moment où les médecins l'ont
dit et que dans un pays on a pris une
décision vous êtes infirmière vous
n'êtes pas médecin
de faire des injections alors nous en
tant que
décision conflit d'intérêt d'accord on
gagne 1500 1600 € par mois je pense
qu'on a le droit d'avoir un esprit
critique et qu'un produit expérimental
qu'on informe pas la population que
c'est un produit encore en face de ces
clinique les gens avaient le droit et on
avait le devoir de les informer donc ne
pas les informer c'est leur mentir déjà
et ensuite
le médecin d'informait pas à ce
moment-là il y a pas eu de consentement
libre et éclairé c'est ça l'information
dire c'est un produit expérimental on a
six mois de recul à peine donc avec 6
mois de recul ça ne s'est jamais fait
dans l'histoire de des vaccins jamais
auparavant et là pour une histoire de
sécurité sanitaire on va faire de la
population mondiale des cobayes des
cobayes et même les rats voilà je pense
que les rats nous remercient à l'heure
actuelle parce que on a pris la place
des rats de laboratoire donc à un moment
donné moi je tiens la vie je tiens à la
vie de mes patients j'ai toujours traité
les gens à l'hôpital comme si je
soignais ma famille et je suis horrifié
de voir l'indifférence dans laquelle les
gens ont été suspendus l'indifférence
des médias j'avais raison sur un truc
j'avais même oublié pour vous dire et en
plus je suis même dans les médias je
suis quand même fait de l'actualité tous
les jours pour vous dire comme c'est
c'est grave parce que c'est dans une
intelligence totale même moi j'avais
oublié donc c'est important que vous
soyez là ce soir parce que c'est fou je
vous dis je pense que je suis pas le
seul et on le voit il y a des drames qui
se passent à l'hôpital actuellement on a
besoin de tout le personnel hospitalier
je suis désolé là il y a une vraie
question à se poser et c'est vrai que
vous soyez suspendus Florence au-delà de
de bien sûr il y a l'hôpital et votre
métier mais comme vous nous l'avez dit
vous avez une famille et aujourd'hui
déjà que vous gagnez pas bien votre vie
1500 euros par mois vous rendez compte
pour le travail qu'elle fait moi j'avais
10 ans d'ancienneté j'ai choisi de pas
travailler à l'hôpital avec des horaires
décalés tout ça j'étais en centre
médico-psychologique donc j'avais des
horaires à peu près convenables mais je
gagnais 1500 euros j'ai fait le choix de
gagner moins pour privilégier ma famille
mais là j'ai fait le choix de ma vie
d'être en bonne santé parce que mes
enfants ma vie et ben c'est ça le plus
important et puis la vie des gens que je
que je sois une donc mon esprit critique
j'espère qu'il y a encore à l'hôpital
des gens avec un esprit critique et je
sais que à l'hôpital ceux qui se sont
fait injecter donc l'ont fait sous la
contrainte une extorque une extension de
consentement c'est comme ça qu'on
appelle ça on nous a forcé à nous faire
acheter justement Dany Foster de mort
social en fait c'est une mort sociale là
qu'on a subi Florence vous vous êtes
directeur d'EHPAD est-ce que vous avez
forcé vos clients vos passions voilà vos
clients on va dire à ce à non non c'est
les familles qui ont voulu qu'on
vaccinent absolument les résidents
d'EHPAD et c'était important le vacciner
parce que franchement on a eu des décès
dans les EHPAD ça se voit que vous avez
jamais travaillé finalement dans les
services hospitaliers parce que
franchement
excusez-moi on a vécu un cluster quand
il y a un cluster vous avez des
personnes qui décèdent vous avez des
soignants qui sont heureusement vaccinés
et je peux finir parce que vous avez
heureusement des soignants qui sont
parce que sinon il aurait pu personne et
grâce à la vaccination justement ça
permet de limiter les formes graves
justement de limiter aussi la
transmission et dire que vous voulez pas
injecter alors déjà on n'injegez pas
vous vaccinent mais franchement vous
avez mais
vous êtes vraiment infirmière
sérieusement mais vraiment infirmière
vous êtes vous êtes dans une démarche
meurtrière vous êtes dans une démarche
directeur
je vous dis clairement que si moi
j'avais mes parents dans votre service
croyez-moi
le décrire
juste que des conneries je vous dirais
hiver mectine hydroxychloroquine il y
avait des traitements qu'on a interdit
que le gouvernement interdit on a dit
aux gens dans les EHPAD vous savez vous
êtes minoritaire qui sont suspendus sur
le territoire national
non mais franchement c'est grave et
heureusement que vous êtes suspendu et
j'espère vous allez rester changer de
métier vraiment pour la paix sociale
comme vous on en veut pas dans les EHPAD
dans leur chambre égoïste qui a été
croyez-moi que les soignants ils veulent
pas vous voir quand il vous ayez prier
les gens et écoutez parce que moi ça
m'énerve en fait de voir des gens comme
vous cariériste qui veulent juste de
l'oseille c'est tout moi
de la vie humaine d'accord parlez pas de
Matthieu de l'embou comme ça non c'est
pour des tonnes un peu l'atmosphère
Béatrice moi j'avais ma grand alors
franchement c'est un sujet qui me touche
beaucoup parce que ma grand-mère était
dans un EHPAD pendant la crise sanitaire
elle avait 100 ans elle a refusé de se
vacciner c'était son choix on ne pouvait
pas lui imposer elle avait toute sa tête
et vous l'avez disque et pas vous parce
qu'elle était pas dans votre EHPAD mais
elle a été discriminée on avait plus le
droit d'aller dans sa chambre on a eu 20
minutes pour fêter ses 100 ans on a eu
20 minutes avec elle on était obligé de
l'avoir les derniers jours vous allez me
laisser finir parce que c'est quelque
chose qui me touche énormément elle est
décédée depuis elle n'est pas morte du
covid elle ne l'a jamais attrapé alors
qu'elle était qu'à contact toutes les
semaines et qu'elle n'était pas et ils
l'ont harcelé pour qu'elle se vaccinent
absolument vous exagérez comme
vous rendez compte que vous dites
[Musique]
la vaccination et on respecte le choix
j'ai dû la voir dans un salon en bas ils
ont avec un enfant d'accord je suis
d'accord j'ai eu 20 minutes avec elle
pour son anniversaire de ses 100 ans et
ça je ne pardonnerai jamais où est le
droit le choix libre et éclairer des
gens
entre les droits des visites et le
consentement la vaccination c'était de
la répression parce qu'elle avait refusé
de se vacciner c'est uniquement ça voilà
donc ne venez pas donner de leçon de
morale s'il vous plaît est-ce que des
gens comme ma grand-mère il y en a
beaucoup qui ont été isolés de leur
famille à cause de ça
vous les avez enfermés dans leur chambre
j'étais là pendant le covid j'ai
toujours été là et j'ai travaillé
pendant plus de 10 ans à l'hôpital
dans le covid pendant la crise sanitaire
du covid 2020 2020
parce que oui j'ai mal vécu tout ça oui
j'ai été mon collègues
vous êtes dans un EHPAD vous parlez pour
la pour qui en fait je parle au nom des
soignants vous savez j'ai commencé en
tant que soignants de base donc oui je
pense que là
justement j'ai remis ma blouse et
heureusement et heureusement qu'on était
vaccinés parce qu'on a pu continuer à
s'occuper des résidents on a besoin de
vous je suis désolé de consentement
libre et éclairé arrêter de mentir
quand on vous écoute et Gilles les
propos que tu tiens en fait j'ai
l'impression d'être dans tes PMP il y a
un an en fait il y a un an que vous
auriez pu tu aurais pu tenir ses propos
mais là on a quand même vu on a le
propos ben les propos que oui il faut se
vacciner et que de toute façon les
aides-soignants qui sont pas vaccinés il
faut les il faut les dégager et tout ça
mais aujourd'hui on a vu que il n'y a
voilà même c'était vacciné tu peux avoir
le covid même à plusieurs reprises tu
peux même le mettre et aujourd'hui quand
on en parle même plus quand quelqu'un
éternue bah tu lui dis à tes souhaits tu
penses même plus au covid il y a des
gens qui se galochent ici il y a des
gens qui vont en discothèque tout le
monde se mélange donc les grands voilà
donc
sans oublier aujourd'hui les grands
oubliés ce sont les aides-soignants le
personnel soignant c'est passé sous
silence parce qu'autrement tout le monde
a repris sa vie sert plus aucun souci il
y a plus aucun covid alors s'il vous
plaît remettez ces soignants pour que
des gens ne meurent pas de de de
maltraitance volontaire ou involontaire
disons c'est très très important selon
le ministère de la Santé vous seriez
ou administratif de la santé être
suspendu 12000 on a les chiffres donc
c'est 12000 c'est beaucoup euh
en oubliant ceux qui sont en arrêt ou
qui ont fait des faux exactement voilà
c'est ça qui ont fait des faux qui sont
là exactement c'est vrai ça ils sont pas
pris en compte je suis d'accord avec
vous Florence tout à fait c'est vrai que
ça c'est les chiffres officiels voilà et
12000 donc c'est beaucoup plus ça doit
être quatre fois plus à mon avis je
pense voilà ça doit être aux alentours
de 50000
personnels suspendus parce qu'ils sont
souvent en arrêt comme vous dites ou
ceux qui pour ceux qui ont eu faire
défaut parce que ils pouvaient pas se
retrouver sans salaire c'est ça et puis
même celui qui travaille dans le service
technique qui est pas du tout en lien
avec le
pour s'occuper des patients et pour
s'occuper des résidents d'epad mais vous
savez que même les patients mais ils ne
veulent pas des personnes irresponsables
comme vous je suis désolé mais oui vous
êtes en plus des gens infirmières vous
avez fait 3 ans d'études ou pas vraiment
vous avez appris la pharmacie
c'est moi tranquille me parlez pas
justement ma priorité c'est justement ce
que des patients
au mieux c'est les respecter et un
consentement libre et éclairé respecter
le serment d'Hippocrate pour les
médecins c'est la base ne pas avoir de
conflits d'intérêt c'est la base on a vu
que la plupart des médecins qui étaient
sur les plateaux télé ils en avaient on
a vu que les gens des directeurs d'Ehpad
aussi avaient plus d'intérêt à avoir de
l'argent que du pays du bien-être ou des
patients dans les conditions dans
lesquelles on traite les gens en EHPAD
vous inquiétez pas c'est vous qui
maltraitez finalement si vous voulez
revenir c'est une forme de majorité
depuis que j'ai 18 ans
ou pas non merci
non tu as mis oui mais tu as pas c'est
tout voilà très bien j'ai dit oui moi je
pense qu'il faut réintégrer les les
personnes qui pourraient qui sont prêtes
à travailler qui n'ont plus de salaire
pour leur famille plus rien on doit les
réintégrer voilà c'est mon avis on
distribue alimentaire enfin moi je fais
partie d'une Association porteur
d'espérance on fait des distributions de
paniers alimentaires entre autres pour
les soignants tous les jeudis je sais
pas on a pendant le Pass sanitaire ils
avaient même pas le droit d'aller au
resto du coeur parce qu'il fallait le
passe sanitaire mais je sais pas où est
l'humanité où est l'humanité on prend
les gens qui sentent concernés
qu'est-ce que tu penses des propos de
flots Florence et de et de ce directeur
des pâtes de Dany je trouve Dany très
excessif envers Florence mais moi
Florence j'ai une question à vous poser
une question humaine en fait derrière ce
débat il y a le fait que vous refusez le
vaccin ce qui est tout à fait votre
droit mais comment vous expliquer que en
Italie et même en France ça monte les
soignants qui ont été vaccinés ne
veulent pas que les non vaccinés
reviennent c'est qu'ils estiment qu'il y
a un danger il vous n'êtes pas désiré
comment vous l'expliquez ça
en Italie
ça c'est des oui dire c'est c'est de la
manipulation pour moi c'est manipulation
les médias veulent faire croire aux gens
pour introduire ça dans la tête ah on
veut pas des méchants criminels est-ce
qu'on est des criminels quelle faute on
a commis il doit vouloir vous vacciner
tout en continuant
moi je veux soigner des gens mais
comment dire en respectant leur volonté
et en les informant entièrement mais
voilà si c'est un traitement
expérimental il faut leur dire on leur a
caché moi mes patients on a voulu leur
cacher moi mon travail c'était de leur
dire la vérité je l'ai fait
la dose de vaccin jamais mais ceux qui
voulaient il y avait pas de souci je les
ai pas je leur ai dit voilà c'est encore
expérimental mais chacun est libre de
faire ce qu'ils avaient dit que vous
avez refusé on a toujours pas de revenus
là-bas
jamais je travaillerai pour vous
monsieur
quand vous dites j'ai refusé de piquer
de vacciner certaines personnes c'était
des personnes qui ne voulaient pas en
psychiatrie et pour moi des personnes
vulnérables qui n'ont pas toute leur
compétences on va dire et je pouvais pas
leur mentir et puis il fallait les
médecins les pousser en fait à
l'injection en leur disant voilà sinon
il y aura plus de consultation sinon
vous pourrez pas vous faire hospitaliser
c'était le chantage comme nous après le
chantage à la vie au travail la mort
sociale voilà ne plus avoir de salaire
du tout moi je connais des couples des
couples infirmiers ou soignants tous les
deux travaillent à l'hôpital suspendu
depuis le 15 septembre 0 € les deux
Gilles tu es resté bloqué en 2020 et
pardon mais ta position elle est
profondément inhumaine en fait on dit
tous le covid ces dernières nous mais
c'est facile de dire ça qu'on est assis
tranquille tu peux bosser tous les soirs
mais il y a des milliers ou des dizaines
de milliers de personnes et même si
c'est 12000 c'est 12000 de trop qui ne
peuvent pas bosser qui n'ont pas d'aide
et moi ce qui me gêne c'est que j'ai
l'impression que les décisionnaires de
cette mesure veulent de venger des
non-voxines donc on a compris que vous
les emmerdez mais jusqu'où ça va aller
en fait on va les laisser crever
plus jamais travailler de leur vie c'est
c'est inhumain comme décision c'est
dégueulasse
alors on va voir ce qu'on pense à
téléspectateurs regardez oui à 80 % non
à 19 %, on est sûr on les comprend et
c'est vrai que moi je lâche pas ça a été
fait par tout je comprends pas pourquoi
en France ça n'est pas fait je suis
désolé j'ai le Verdez mais là je suis
pas d'accord avec toi mon Gilou et je
pense que les personnels on en a
tellement besoin du personnel soignant
et en plus les laisser sans salaire des
mois comme ça franchement c'est c'est
inadmissible je suis désolé comment ils
font comment tu fais comment tu fais
c'est un drame je le sais très bien oui
c'est un drame humain
la première vague sont allés travailler
avec des sacs poubelles et des voilà
lorsque vous avez quelque chose à
rajouter soit ben je suis choquée et
triste en fait je pense vraiment à tous
mes tous les gens que j'ai rencontré
dans cette lutte en fait parce qu'on est
on est entré en centre de résistance et
on essaye de soutenir du mieux qu'on
peut mais c'est des vies brisés c'est
des gens qui se sont suicidés aussi mais
c'est des gens qui ont énormément de
courage parce que c'est pas un caprice
en fait ça me
touche énormément merci de nous de
m'avoir invité c'est important pour moi
c'est beaucoup de colère parce que c'est
un gouvernement qui est hors-sol aussi
et qui croit qui est dans l'ego sûrement
et qui veut pas revenir sur une loi qui
n'a aucun sens et donc c'est gravissime
en fait ses erreurs si vous pouvez pas
réintégrer là vous savez faire
orienter changer de carrière et c'est
déjà réfléchi je vais être dans la santé
mais plus dans la prévention j'ai plus
envie de servir Big Pharma j'ai plus
envie d'être complice de tout ça
Denis vous avez un dernier mot à dire
bon en tout cas je voulais vraiment
remercier tous les soignants qui ont
accepté de faire vacciner parce que pour
certains ils étaient contre et après ils
ont finalement acceptés donc je pense
qu'il y a quand même faut les finances
ils ont accepté aussi parce que sinon
on va on va pas se mentir il y en a
beaucoup qui ont accepté parce qu'ils
sont dit bah sinon je suis foutu dehors
non seulement parce qu'ils étaient
responsables et je pense que c'est
important
et je vous dis la vérité Dany bien sûr
qu'il y en a qui voulait se faire
vacciner ça je suis sûr mais tous il y
en avait qui se posaient peut-être des
questions comme on a dit beaucoup de
décès quand même vous avez vu dans les
EHPAD il y en a qui l'ont fait parce que
sinon ils étaient disqualifiés de la
société disqualifiés de du service
musical pas du tout je pense qu'il faut
quand même remercier tous les soignants
qui a accepté de faire vacciner moi je
remercie les soignants tout court c'est
quand même une minorité et je pense
qu'il ne faut pas réintégrer les
soignants non vaccinés on enverrait un
mauvais signal pour les soignants
accepté tous les soignants et puis je
pense qu'il faut vraiment réintégrer les
soignants qui sont responsables et non
pas des soignants comme on pense les
malheureusement
fermement et d'ailleurs le gouvernement
est dans le même sens et d'ailleurs les
autorités aussi sanitaires sont contre
parce que franchement c'est je pense que
aller dans les services hospitaliers
allez voir enfin il y a eu beaucoup de
décès mais si évidemment il y a derrière